but when you have a dream  it doesn't often come at you screaming  in your face this is who you are this is  what you must be for the rest of your  life sometimes a dream almost Whispers  And I've always said to my kids  the hardest thing to listen to your  instincts your human personal intuition  always Whispers it never shouts very  hard to hear so you have to every day of  your lives be ready to hear what  Whispers In Your Ear it very rarely  shouts and if you can listen to the  whisper and if it tickles your heart and  it's something you think you want to do  for the rest of your life then that is  going to be what you do for the rest of  your life and we will benefit from  everything you do thank you very much  [Music]